le tirage pour retrouver le jouet du roi
de rome cette domestique à une des
demandes et à des enfants de retracer
une des journées habituel de l'aiglon le
fils de napoléon 1er
on appelait en premier il a récupéré le
château de rambouillet lorsqu'il l'accès
de pouvoir et il a passé 60 jours ici au
château de rambouillet donc ça peut
sembler très peu 60 jours mais napoléon
1er c'est quelqu'un qui passait
énormément de temps en campagne et du
coût 60 jours c'était énorme pour lui ce
matin très enfants ont relevé le défi
des épreuves pour des enfants âgés de 4
à 6 ans qui les transportent de pièce en
pièce au coeur du château
on est en bonne santé après on était de
celles engagées dans la journée avec une
histoire c'est super pour moi aussi
parce que effectivement comme j'ai pas
eu le temps d'aller d'y aller avant leur
naissance
c'est l'occasion de mêler l'utile à
l'agréable et puis moi aussi de
découvrir l'histoire du château de mon
super laban c'est le jouet que le roi de
rome avait égaré ses enfants sont
parvenus à la trouver et vous